In this lecture, we start our
discussion of continuous
random variables.
We will focus on the case of
a single continuous random
variable, and we'll describe
its distribution using a
so-called probability density
function, an object that will
replace the PMFs from
the discrete case.
We will then proceed to define
the expectation and the
variance of a continuous random
variable, and we'll see
that their basic properties
remain unchanged.
There will be one
new concept--
the cumulative distribution
function, which will allow us
to describe, in a unified
manner, both discrete and
continuous random variables,
even so-called mixed random
variables that have both
a discrete and
a continuous component.
In the course of this lecture,
we will also introduce some of
the most common continuous
random variables--
uniform, exponential,
and normal.
We will pay special attention to
the normal distribution and
the ways that we can calculate
the associated probabilities.